we begin this hour with a big unveiling
overseas the artist christo and his wife
jean-claude achieve worldwide fame for
their decades of oversized art
installations from surrounding a string
of florida islands and vibrant pink
fabric to draping new york central park
in billowing orange both have since
passed away but as of this morning one
of their earliest artistic visions has
finally been realized
holly williams is in paris holly good
morning
good morning this is the arc de triomphe
and one very controversial work of art
it cost more than 16 million dollars and
will only be in place for just over two
weeks but on the streets of paris we
found that people have fallen back in
love with a landmark they'd taken for
granted
it took four years of planning and 270
000 square feet of silver polypropylene
fabric to wrap the arcta triomphe from
its crown to its giant feet
it now looms over the champs-elysees
like a shimmering spaceship stopping
blase parisians in their tracks
superb you like
i like it
usually i i i i go down and up and in in
the chance that you never see out the
tree today i see how the queen it was
conceived in 1962 by the artist christo
and his partner jean-claude they also
wrapped the reichstag building in berlin
the sydney coastline and 11 islands off
miami christo famously said that art is
irrational and useless its only point to
delight the senses
he's an unstoppable source of excitement
jean-claude passed away in 2009 followed
by christo last year it feels almost
like
his nephew vladimir javasev oversaw this
project and told us criticism is normal
i mean it's very human that not of all
of us to agree and everybody's opinion
and interpretation is legitimate they
can it's a work of art you can take it
in so many ways when you think of a
french architectural icon the eiffel
tower may spring to mind but for many
french people it's this place the arc de
triomphe that symbolizes their national
identity
it was built as a memorial to fallen
french soldiers
and through the centuries it's witnessed
catastrophic defeats general eisenhower
glorious victories and vandalism during
street protests in 2018.
and berghardt is a structural engineer
who protected the arch as it was wrapped
from the beginning beginning on for us
it was clear that we have to make an
extraordinary job here not to damage
anything and to take very good care of
their acted humans
when the french president emmanuel
macron visited the project he said quote
this is what we believe in crazy dreams
must come true
michelle i love it holly thank you so
much i so remember the gates as well as
central new york
it's amazing and it is the idea that
some people love it some people hate it
and and the conversation that it sparks
from there exactly